[Music]
welcome back to yank speaks everybody
happy thursday it's your favorite
co-hosts that are not named andrew yang
you've got zach browman and carly riley
we are back on today's episode we are
talking about
china is banning video games
or limiting massively how many hours
kids can play video games in their
country and it's fascinating elizabeth
holmes founder of theranos is on trial
and we're talking about space junk
finally
finally talking about space junks or
finally talk about elizabeth holmes
finally finally elizabeth holmes is on
trial
uh
and it's funny because uh carly somewhat
looks like elizabeth holmes uh just as
brunette and we're gonna dive into that
uh it's kind of a sore spot for i think
they're really yeah yeah it doesn't feel
great i'm going to be a little bit about
it it's cool
um
quick reminder though guys there's a lot
of fun stuff coming on pike for this
podcast andrew's books coming out
october 5th made some news this week
that we're not going to talk about
because politico is just leaking stuff
they don't necessarily know what's going
on so they said there was a story that
andrew yang may be starting a third
party no one knows no comment i don't
even know what they're talking about
uh all will be
revealed
when the book launches on october 5th uh
and more importantly i'm still in
mourning because the bill's lost this
weekend
carly's first trip to buffalo which
we'll talk about but uh on more positive
news
let's talk about china
china donald trump would say why not um
so look uh
wait can you can i just start off so
because i think you understand this
better than i do in terms of the just
like what exactly is going on
my outside perspective is
china recently this week i'll be curious
like when
basically banned kids under 18 from
playing more than three hours of video
games
just like country wide or is this on a
specific platform
that's me framing what i so far know
about this and i have a very strong
reaction to that is this is that right
am i correct
here's happened and this is probably
most of us have not
one of the things we want to do is
podcasts try and bring up things that
have been
either brushed under the rug or not
talked about uh wow everyone's freaking
out about about aoc's dress the met gala
which frankly who cares um
so look
there's a new law or i guess in china
maybe it's a rule uh
a new law in china that restricts people
under the age of 18 so children to only
play three hours of video games a week
so they limit you if you're under the
age of 18 from playing one you're only
allowed to play one hour a day from 8
p.m to 9 p.m on only fridays saturdays
and sundays according to a local news
agency there uh okay when did this go
into effect
this went into effect uh it just got
passed they're trying to delay it so you
know this past week um you get the exact
date it was it was or like
30th of august is when the news came out
yeah okay so we're talking about two
weeks ago
this is like not
something that i'm seeing places like i
wasn't seeing it on twitter
like is that the same for you are you
seeing this places this news i've seen
it all um i'm not sure how you found it
um but i've been diving in and now
here's the deal maybe it's less big news
because china actually limited
the length of time that kids could play
under 18 kids could play video games to
one and a half hours a day and three
hours on holidays um
in a rule pass in 2019 so it's not
completely out of character for the
chinese to ban this but this is pretty
nice um
and they have these gaming companies
that require this include cell phones to
xbox to computer games they have to use
real name verification systems um
but frankly like kids can still use
their parents account just like you
would get around this so it's very
interesting so
i wanted to so look
china does a whole bunch of crazy things
carly and i are not pretending to be an
expert on video games or uh
these types of laws however i thought it
was very interesting like authoritarian
freedom and debate um and i think you
and i came down on different sides of
this carly so you hate this law
am i correct well my reaction is like
are you
effing kidding me yeah of course like
what could like
you know i'm thinking about if you know
in the future i have a kid and it's a
rough week i mean
screw it let's take it to the extreme
right like you have a like you have a
death in the family and it's a really
and you're like
you know you're really upset as a parent
and you're just like hey i just need my
kids to be able to like zone out and be
out of my hair and if that means that
for like one week they're spending like
20 freaking hours because it's the
summer and they're not in school like
playing video games the idea that as a
parent
that's not within my right and the state
actually is saying that's not allowed
like blows my mind and i guess it
shouldn't because of course china is a
you know communist country and they have
a dictatorship and this isn't like a
free normal society they're you know
there's essentially a genocide against
uyghurs like there's so much about china
that's completely different from from
the united states but i think because it
is one of the world's superpowers and
and it's it gets talked about a lot and
it just somehow is hitting me as like
incredible that that
that is the way that a whole huge part
of the population lives is
with that kind of government oversight
and control
i think in your example like parents
could let a kid have their own login uh
but look i think you're talking about
restricting
you start to get into like a public
health debate um
and that's why i'm like less i don't
love this law but i think it's pretty
crazy like an hour a day
all weekend like what um like you know
they kind of start to restrict fun to a
certain point but here's the deal so i
don't love restricting things i like
governments and also i don't like
government trying to enforce things they
can't really enforce like this can be
hard on force um
but i do love things that are good for
kids like right now we have a generation
of children um who are now
and now adults who are
legitimately addicted to their
smartphones um right now according to
i mean i looked at a whole bunch of
references here um but reviews.org did a
survey that's not but
this is one of many i found but they
this one has 75 of americans consider
self-reported that they're addicted to
cell phones um they're addicted to their
own phone and according their survey
about 2-3 000 people about 65 percent of
americans check their phone up to 160
times
per day which is
you know every six minutes or so
depending on you how math you want to do
but it's a lot um
and combat combined with what we've
talked about in the us and this is
global where we have a mental health
crisis um
as a society right now we are more
distant we are more alone we are more
insecure we are less empathetic we are
less forgiving we are more angry these
are not good things these are frankly
terrible things so is your argument your
argument is like this is essentially
similar to the government saying hey if
you're under 18 you can't smoke
cigarettes right like
we control
things all the time when it comes to
kids and governments control things
about kids when it comes to
health and that that this would fall in
that category
correct that's their i mean their quote
they quoted in a national press and
public uh publication administration
said teenagers are the future of our
motherland
protecting their physical and mental
health of minors is related to all the
people's vital interests um
so
look this is a mental and public health
move and so here's the deal like this is
a this is a disaster and like globally
it's not getting better right this is
like these things are accelerating
they're getting worse they're not
getting better so we have a choice as a
society we can do nothing and shrug
or we could try and implement new things
so i don't support this law i think it's
too restrictive
um do you know what is the enforcement
mechanism for this like how do they
actually
control this so they use gamer
verification services and they require
the companies to do it and so um they
will acquire you i don't know
mechanically we'd have to talk somebody
who's
probably a minor who's growing china
right now um
but
uh
you know you have to have a legitimate
account um tied to yourself for your
gaming account um
which comes a whole lot another
challenge i'm not saying this is easy to
enforce but my my point is i'm plotting
that they're trying to do something like
they didn't make video games illegal
they'd be restricted how much you play
as a child um
and i think this is what we're missing
today government that tries new things
now i don't love like trying things on a
national scale i think i love that about
the united states you have like local
communities and this should be done
community by community and city by city
and state by state and what works for
you but
i applaud attempting to protect kids uh
in a way that's not
i mean you're really hurting you're
gonna be canceled again you're
applauding the the chinese government
uh that i bought the intent i don't like
the law
it makes sense
so what
yeah
no i mean i think that's interesting i i
would be really curious to understand a
little bit more about how exactly they
they plan to enforce this the the
verification piece makes sense i mean
um it's a huge hit to the gaming
industry because obviously china is a
huge epicenter of gaining
international for sure and uh
so to have this kind of limitation is um
you know it's interesting how that will
continue today
for sure
and we had um
we had uh what's his name pricing on
talk about esports and talk about all
the benefits of gaming
yeah well we talked about all the
benefits of playing video games the kids
learn to collaborate better and
communicate better that's why i'm not
like sold on this law but here's what i
will say and i think that's what we're
missing like
we need to make hard decisions
governments need to make hard decisions
the same way parents do like letting
like or we just make the easy decision
and everything goes to [ __ ] like letting
your kid play unlimited video games is
easy that's the easy way out it's easier
on the parent like i just distract the
child and the kid is great because like
i get to play video games all day you
know it's not easy in the long run in
the long run
well it's not easy in the long run is
dealing with a [ __ ] kid who can't
communicate or can't or always guess
what they want or learns right or wrong
from video game chat rooms which are
notoriously under chaperoned or
unchaperoned so
i'm against this law because it seems a
little too authoritarian and this seems
a little too far but i'm in favor of
trying new stuff and so
again should be done at local level city
by city like communities should start to
do this i mean i think it's interesting
i see i see your argument i you know
it's probably not as ridiculous as it
felt like it was to me on the face of it
it is surprising to me though that
it was surprising to me that i hadn't
seen this that i had to actively be
looking for interesting stories for the
purpose of this podcast to find this
because that's why i bring it up like
how is this not talked about and it
wasn't talking about 2019 either as much
as i i don't support the
i don't support this kind of government
intervention
i mean
like
it does support the narrative that
china's just going to continue to eat
our lunch right because
they they have the ability to impose
draconian measures that can make for
very effective
productive citizens
and
you know that's who we're competing
against and increasingly competing
against in a global workforce and in a
global economy
so
you know i think
it should give parents uh
food for thought here in this country of
like how are you monitoring your kids uh
technology consumption um
because
we're probably frying the brains of a
lot of american youth oh yeah
and what's what's crazy is and we were
talking this last episode time out like
when the government tries to regulate
things it can be a disaster like there's
there's difference in the morality in
the practice right um but we are
entering an era where
we're not going to have a choice because
inaction will
is becoming more and more unacceptable
and that's kind of where i'm like struck
like where i'm at here like normally
this law like this like banning video
games like what the hell like let us
have our thing right let us like who
cares right
but it's actually frying children's
brains and it's actually making all of
us more depressed and angry and more
isolated and all the things that you're
like the numbers
because we just said that video games
actually come with a lot of benefits do
we need to distinguish between video
games and just like mindless social
media scrolling like well no i think
anything in excess becomes a disaster
and so i agree with you you could
distinguish between social media and
that sort of click bait stuff and video
and um
you know there's a difference between
those but
um
i don't think there's any evidence that
letting a child play video games
whenever he or she wants it at all hours
is
a net positive for the child
um
you know i think like most things in
moderation it's like you'd say the same
thing about someone who played
basketball 24 7. it might stunt their
development in other areas um
so
and not video game basketball real
basketball so i look i don't know
if
government intervention is the answer
here but at some point
i know social media is the bigger
problem um or just addiction to
smartphones in general which video games
are a part of um
this is
getting worse not better we have to do
something um i'd rather do something
than nothing and or we just all embrace
the ready player one future that we are
going to enter someday uh no i kid i
think all right
tweeted us your initial reaction to this
to hearing about this let us know if
you've heard about it previously or if
this is the first you're hearing about
it if you're also shocked that this
wasn't more of a thing that people were
talking about maybe it really is just me
but this just felt like um really
fascinating to to learn that this was
going on so i'm carly p reilly on
twitter what are you zach rahman
zach underscore grumman but if you just
look up zach graham and i think if i
find me excuse me
um i for i i think i own zach grauman
but i lost the password it's a long
story anyway um but this getting worse
not better like and one of the things
we're not gonna talk deep down but
facebook
has a partnership with ray-ban right now
and you can literally
like ima remember remember what the snap
glasses were that snapchat came out with
what were they called snap goggles i
don't remember um no i don't know they
have those but they're cooler like way
cooler way smaller more effective um so
what are they for i don't understand
you can take video at any time without
anyone noticing like there's stuff that
do we now it's kind of the same as a
smartphone right now anyone can
videotape you people do all the time but
it's just gonna be more
easy to access unaware it's happening
kids are addicted adults are addicted
like it's the wild west at some point
the government's probably gonna have to
do something while there's mall going to
[ __ ] um
and i think we should pick people over
the money like i think the gaming
industry can take a small hit oh i don't
care about that either but i also pick
freedom over like this is where i i
start to be a little conservative right
it's like i i very much value a parent's
ability to make decisions about their
own kids as opposed to the government
stepping in and making those decisions
so that that's where the deeper
questions are i think all this stuff
works when you educate your populace um
but agreed okay
[Music]
[Applause]
real talk how is your mental health if
it's like mine probably not that great
i'm losing my mind postcode getting a
little better and the reason i'm getting
better is because of our sponsor better
betterhelp which is
amazing secure
and well frankly fairly priced
counseling done securely online so you
can start communication and get paired
with
a licensed professional
on a safe private online environment
that's super convenient within 48 hours
it's not a crisis line it's not
self-help it's professional counseling
done securely online you can talk to
your counselor anytime you get timely
and thoughtful responses i love my
counselor it's freaking awesome and you
can get advice on depression or anger or
stress or family complex whatever you're
going through
better help is freaking awesome and it's
confidential convenient professional
affordable all the things you need done
conveniently online so i want you to
start living a happier life today and as
a listener you're going to get 10 off
your first month by visiting our sponsor
betterhelp.com yang so join over 1
million people
taking charge of their mental health
again that's betterhelp
help.com
yang
sports have long been an important and
defining part of our history
with their impact and influence
key moments in sports have helped shape
heal
and inspire it has been said that i have
two alternatives
either go to jail
or go to the army
but i would like to say that there is
another alternative
that alternative is justice
i'm doc rivers and i'm proud to present
a new podcast documentary series called
it was said sports
where i guide you through six of the
most impactful and timeless speeches in
sports history the question has already
been answered
should we be here
yes
listen and follow it was said sports a
documentary podcast presentation of
shining city audio a c13 originals and
john meacham studio
available now wherever you listen to
your podcast
okay elizabeth holmes
uh
yeah this one this one's personal
because i i do i don't know in this
particular moment in this particular
video if i if i'm gonna come across as
looking like her but there there is a
certain level of resemblance there
what do you mean
do you do this
well no you really want to know what it
is it's my jowls right like i have sort
of a
yeah i have a heavy bottom weighted face
you can't really tell your eyes are
similar i don't know about the nose the
eyes it's the jowls it's the you know
whatever the worst people to be if you
google
her well she's i think engaged still to
like a
multi-millionaire billionaire like
hotelier or something so she's doing
just like oh that's surprising she loves
the fancy life okay let's talk about
home for those who don't know
so
backstory on elizabeth holmes i mean i'm
sure most everyone knows there's a quick
story of their nose but i'm gonna give
you the 30 seconds
and and i will say if you are interested
if you like
like
like big huge cons in the corporate
world
this is a great one and the book um i
think it's called bad blood by john
kerry
that's the one there was an hbo
documentary also awesome yeah it's that
that might be based on bad blood anyhow
and john kerry rooney has a podcast
where he's tracking the current trial of
elizabeth holmes okay here we go called
the inventor out for blood in silicon
valley great
elizabeth holmes stanford student drops
out of stanford because she decides to
pursue
a business
where basically she's able to test
people for
a whole range of diseases so she claims
with just a prick of blood so she sets
out to say how can we revolutionize like
blood the blood drawing industry because
as anyone knows right now
you get your blood drawn to test for all
different things and that process is
like kind of horrible i actually am like
around it
you know it's like a needle in your arm
they put this tourniquet around you like
it's it's a pretty takes forever tough
to read forever
it's awful so she was like we're
revolutionizing this now we're gonna
disrupt it a pin prick of blood
we can test for all the things that you
used to have to get a whole blood draw
for so she's like i believe 19 years old
when she drops out of stanford to start
pursuing this she was a biotech
whatever major at stanford
and
she becomes one of the hottest tech
properties in silicon valley so the
theranos board is like crazy it's henry
kissinger it's george schultz who was a
senior political member of the reagan
administration
um
you'll note interestingly none of those
people have a background in science or
biotech conveniently
um and it gets a valuation i think of
like nine billion dollars at its peak
she's on the cover of all these
magazines as you know a billionaire
she's very jobs like
if you watch her
like
ted to or like her pitch it's pretty
awesome oh she's like super masterful
salesperson as all great con artists are
we all drink
everybody if you if you've heard
elizabeth holmes ever and and again this
may all be repeat for folks but she has
this very deep voice now one of my
favorite internet conspiracies is that
that is not elizabeth holmes real voice
there's not a lot of like weight to it
but there are a couple of people who say
they knew her when she was younger or
knew her at stanford before she dropped
out like a professor who says that her
voice was not like that and there's this
podcast interview if you want to go deep
you can look this up there's this
podcast interview with elizabeth holmes
where for like a split second
she like reverts into a voice and a
laugh that sound
so much more natural like it you just
have this moment where you're like oh
that sounds like her and it's much
higher pitched it's nothing like her
deep voice and then it immediately flips
back to like the weird deep raspy
elizabeth holmes he does kind of talk
like this it's very strange and i think
there's a really interesting you know
conversation there about
that you know one of the one of the few
women to pull off a con like this also
happens to kind of sound masculine and
what does that mean in terms of how
people tend to trust masculine voices
more i don't know i feel like people
have done pods on this although like
she's a fascist i'm sure i just guess
yeah so anyhow you know the the punch
line here is that the whole thing was
essentially a fraud which is to say
she was claiming to investors she was
claiming to the public that the
technology they had was way further
along than it actually was and the
terrifying thing was that she had
actually established partnerships with i
believe it was walgreens with like
with with pharmacies around the country
using her technology
and
and people were getting misdiagnosed on
the basis of theranos and their
technology in fact they were getting
blood samples sent back and thoroughs
was using other companies technology to
try and get diagnoses because their own
tech was so bad so it you know total
disaster john kerry was the one who
broke this story and eventually broke
this con
she had a you know a fabulous fall from
grace and her her trial was supposed to
be last year during covet or during
covert at some point it got pushed back
and now here finally
we are hopefully having our our day of
retribution
elizabeth holmes is on trial and we will
see if she actually serves prison time
which she of course should and i would
be shocked if she did not
for defrauding investors for putting
public safety at in jeopardy et cetera
yeah so trousers go 13 weeks or so she's
facing up to 20 years in prison there's
a couple podcasts on this we'll link to
them because we're not elizabeth home
experts we're just
fans of entrepreneurship and having fun
watching this nonsense uh
i think
here's a couple thoughts i have real
quick carl i think
um
one
i'm like torn i guess is what i'm saying
um so one so her defense actually clear
her defense is gonna be that she was in
a relationship with the
ceo and that's funny
and that he was a real manipulative one
which is going to be fascinating to
watch but here's my here's why i'm
talking on one end i think people should
be punished actually more severely for
this i think it's kind of yes
then
uh
i mean most other crimes i think it's
like like i think you should be up there
with i mean i guess it's tough to say is
like morally equivalent of like murder
or types of types of violence but
no no i believe she's a sociopath and
she's a menace to society because she
did put people's lives at risk i mean
she was
by by by her own just fortune nobody did
die because of misdiagnosis of their
noses but like somebody could have died
so it's simply convenient that nobody
did one person so then miscarriage never
had another person was told they had uh
i think it was colon cancer
um like she messed with people lied to
people like investors a lot of patients
like the whole thing um
so i i think like 20 years doesn't sound
like enough when you think about it i'm
not maybe hype but it seems extremely
wrong um especially given like how much
we praised this like knowing it was a
lie it's like epic to see um the second
thing though on the other hand my other
thing is torn is like
i know the american appetite and you and
i are contributing to it right now to
like watch people fall or it's like you
see somebody go up like it's like a
human instinct in some ways and this is
an epic story of course it is but it's
like the lance armstrong story it's like
you go down the list of uh like these ep
tiger woods like these epic fall from
braces like we can't get enough of them
and my fear is
in the healthcare space
we need desperately
risk and entrepreneurs and people to get
into this space to disrupt it like that
quest diagnostic company like model is
still dark and messed up now no one
wants to touch it because of this
debacle and so
the other hand i want her to be and she
deserves to be punished i'm sure he's
been punished in many ways too this
hasn't been a fun experience for her but
she hurt a lot of people needs to go to
jail i believe she's a sociopath who
can't feel pain but whatever like i
don't think she feels shame and just
because you're so scared and you feel
pain right no no it is it's it's
pain right no you don't can't feel you
can't feel fear
hmm that's not the definition of
sociopath it is maybe one definition of
sociopath
um
there's a social path like no regard for
anybody else or other other human lives
um
i don't know it doesn't matter the point
is like i i just uh watching this this
this hasn't got a ton of news i mean
it's been covered but it hasn't been as
crazy and particularly like if you're a
gen z if you're young listening this you
probably haven't heard of this because
we only get our news when it goes viral
and it's not really viral yet i'm sure
parts of this will go viral as the trial
comes out but
we'll be watching with baited breath so
how you say that okay
yeah with baited breath uh tests done
for sociopaths like one of the early
tests of sociopaths was they would like
shock people it was done with prisoners
and you would like shock prisoners or do
these horrible prisoners and then that
were painful
and then you would
track their brainwave response in
advance of doing it again and in
sociopaths there was no elevated sense
of fear going into that second wave of
pain whereas for non-sociopaths once
they felt the pain once then they were
anticipatory afraid of the second shock
so there is a thing to there is a
connection between fear and sociopaths
in addition to like the general
anti-social behavior thing um
all right well
i think it's it's interesting yes we
need entrepreneurs to take risks but
certainly
not that he went way way way too far the
fact about elizabeth holmes is that her
father worked for enron which was one of
the other major corporate like just do
we know if he was involved in like
actual enrollment
he was he was too low on the totem pole
but interesting that
you know she saw what happened to enron
and her father lost his job at enron as
a result of obviously enron implemented
fraud yeah well well for those who don't
know enron was also engaged in like
hyper aggressive
that ultimately crossed over into
is what you talk about
practices about like their about how
much their revenue and they were they
were booking revenue they'd like sign a
deal with like a company in india to
build some whatever power plant thing in
like 2025 and they would anticipate all
of the revenue they were ever going to
get from that deal and put it on the
books in like 1997 that's all an
exaggeration but that's essentially what
they were doing which was it was a
market to market accounting or whatever
it was fascinating um people are crazy
um
anyway they should be punished for it um
but in a way that you ideally don't
stifle innovation yeah i'm not worried
about that in the least if people can't
distinguish between taking risks you
know as an entrepreneur and elizabeth
holmes then you should not be in the
entrepreneurial space fair enough
[Music]
whether you realize it or not
you're likely way more creative than you
think
and in a world where we're all sort of
geared towards being a little more
science
than
art i think it's important to bring out
your creative side which is why we
chose to have skillshare as one of our
sponsors on this podcast because they
help you bring out your creative side so
you can take a class to learn to be more
creative in a whole bunch of different
areas right now this is ridiculous but
it's pretty cool i'm taking a class on
indoor gardening and how to grow house
plants because frankly
my new york city apartment could use a
little more
energy yeah that's probably a good way
to put it anyway you can take classes on
how to edit youtube videos or how to do
portrait photography or how to do video
on instagram there's a ton of different
things whether it's a hobby or a side
hustle or just a way you want to learn
to do more things skillshare is pretty
freaking awesome and it's incredibly
affordable especially when compared to
pricey in-person classes or workshops an
annual subscription is less than dollars
a month so right now i want to explore
your creativity with skillshare.com
yang so go to skillshare.com and get one
month free trial of a premium membership
that's one month of a premium membership
at skillshare.com yang become a little
more creative better yourself
skillshare.com
yang
[Music]
[Applause]
okay last thing we want to talk about
space trash because we did an episode on
billionaire's space and there's another
one joining and i love this one i i got
some hate last time i don't care i get
all hair yeah all the time um
but we did an episode on billionaires in
space so you do this one steve wozniak
former co-founder of apple with steve
jobs is launching a space company and
now before you 44 you freak out
it's not like a musk bezos branson
building a rocket company this is
different it's called privateer he's
launching it this week he hasn't
launched it yet we're recording this on
tuesday the 14th but it'll be probably
launched at the
what's it called at the amos tech
festival of maui right now um
maui but
oh yeah maui we should go um
it's called privateer it's a new
satellite company
focused on monitoring and cleaning up
objects in space they get rid of space
junk
and then i went down the rabbit hole
carl
are you aware of the problems we have
with space junk space trash
not at all
i'm fascinated to hear more though here
we are folks um i'm not an expert on
space junk but i have read five articles
from different sources um and use my
critical thinking skills to bring this
to you yang speaks audience so here's
the deal
space has become a dumping ground for
dead satellites um
and launch vehicle rockets basically
it's the wild wild west people like
putting [ __ ] up there and just leaving
it um
and it's not just like companies like
you i you know any
you know media company throws satellite
up there google probably has a bunch of
satellites up there and you know they
get old they launch new ones and they
let that one keep ordering the earth um
in 2019 nasa called
low earth orbit which is where these
satellites and junk are the world's
largest guard garbage jump with nearly 6
000 tons of waste
and it as worn nasa's warmed
warned us that space junks threatened
space goers with garbage hurtling up to
seven times faster than a bullet wait
but so it does it threaten earth or does
it just threaten people not that i don't
know space goes
i can hear the world collectively going
all right let them get hit by space
jumping yeah i know i'm getting the
money to go to the moon
well i don't know like if we're watching
like the first man trip to mars no of
course literally
and this like literally um
paint flex like chips of paint have
smashed shuttle windows like
if you are we're flying the first manned
mission to mars and like
someone's like candy bar rapper flew out
a window and like slices through the
fuel tank and blows it up like that's
gonna be really sad wow so we've
literally already started we've
elon musk is trying to get us to mars
space because we've like successfully
polluted polluted this planet like out
of usability and we're about to
basically pollute space out of usability
before we even get there or at least the
the short yeah the short-term spot
around earth i mean it's not like it's
not okay it's not that you can't clean
it up there's no one's doing it um
there but nasa like nasa monitors the
big ones because they're like this is a
problem so they're monitoring
27 000 pieces of larger space junk which
is god 27 like like people ask what are
your tax dollars coach this [ __ ] um
it's absolutely ridiculous so
and cleanup costs money that we're not
allocating right now so jim
brittenstein who's the
former nasa administrator who is urging
congress to fund a 15 million dollar
cleanup mission
he said in the last two weeks um
said this last year but they've been of
course two weeks there have been three
high concern high concern potential
conjunctions and debris is getting worse
he had tweeted that so
now he may be overblowing it because it
gets some money for this but it is um
they've been talking about this as an ex
exponential problem it just gets worse
over time yeah
well and as you have more like of these
trips out to space right wouldn't it
yeah so what is cool is that this is
actually a pretty cool entrepreneurial
like field um
and
so you have this company that wasn't
starting uh they're still in stealth
mode so we'll see if they have anything
cool but the ideas to solve this is why
i'm so fast the ideas of fixes are right
out of [ __ ] sci-fi it's like lasers
space claws tentacles like magnets you
[ __ ] name it so
the company that the japanese and i
guess in partnership with um the united
kingdom's government our funding is a
company called astro scale which like by
the way if you make a space company you
got to give it a sick name you know um
so
they do they have three things they have
uh what they call end of life services
for satellites so it's like a docking
mechanism you can put on your satellite
that like brings it to its
uh a big-ass magnet to get destroyed or
like they'll have a magnet that like
pulls it through the earth's atmosphere
and like burns that [ __ ] up um
they do active debris removal which i
think they're using magnets and then the
other one they started testing like
magnetic docking systems that would tow
future space junk um and use the
atmosphere as like the incinerous
timeout so
um
i have anyway three minutes so
whatever anyway that's my way of saying
that's freaking awesome yeah yeah
space junk so anyway if you guys are
working on this but if you guys are
working on anything in space junk please
dm me uh because this type of stuff i
want i want to get involved like i feel
left behind like waz didn't call me the
hell uh
anyway good friend of oz
yeah so anyway guys um
that's our show today on a more
important point um the bills are 0-1 and
this supposed to be our super bowl year
so we're very upset but we play miami
next week i took carly to buffalo
uh i had a great what's up first the
whole family experience
yeah and i will say this she missed she
didn't get into late so she missed it
but the
i did have the best buffalo wings ever
had my entire life a place called
barbill
and they were honey butter
barbecue
cajun
buffalo wings they also had the regular
ones which were dynamite too but they
were like
like hubba hubba good you know i'm
saying like
anyway i missed them so i have no
comment but uh great first buffalo
experience growlman's
okay
thank you all we love you all we love
you guys we're super stuff coming down
thanks for continuing to listen
and we'll keep you posted more stuff
coming down the pike see you next
thursday bye
[Music]
you